[Music]
one of the things I love most about
filmmaking and storytelling is sharing
our experiences sharing our stories with
other people it's a way of connecting
with people Travis started a business
that was very successful
like as a cutting-edge stop-motion
animation company obviously we drive as
background in animation he has an
incredible sense of being able to see a
drawing on the page brought to life a
Leica we try to find an artful balance
of darkness and light and intensity and
warmth and humor and heart the idea be
able to bring that kind of philosophy to
them abhi was really exciting I was a
child of the 80s I grew up loving those
classics Spielberg and coming-of-age
tales and that was something that I
wanted to bring to the bumblebee we get
to go back in time with bumblebee and
see where he came from and see him in
his original form
Travis is taking the story back to the
beginning set in the time period where I
first fell in love with transformers
to take this big expansive franchise and
to focus in on a corner of that canvas
we really get to understand who
bumblebee is and why people love him
this is why you're here be
[Music]
let me tell you something
a driver on picnic on
God picked the driver so missus go bomb
between man and machines and mr. Kumar
between man
[Music]
[Music]
who are you
do you speak older you
[Music]
[Applause]
you got people out they will need you
this is why you're here be
and OB music can help you say what
you're feeling try this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you